hey youtubers is Charlie so recently
people were visiting the set of Game of
Thrones Season seven in spotted what is
going to be Daenerys his throne at
Dragonstone she's had several different
Thrones depending on where she's been
throughout the seasons like she had a
throne next to Khal Drogo when she was
with the Dothraki then is her army
toured around she had makeshift Thrones
then she had the throne in the pyramid
so the design of her Thrones are usually
taken from whatever's there if they need
to build something new or put something
together or if one already exists there
like the throne inside the pyramid was
already there they didn't have to build
it for her and it's actually a pretty
plain throne so that's why this is so
much more exciting because she's back at
Dragonstone it's carved into the rock
and it looks like it might be in the
Great Hall I'll explain like the map of
Dragonstone where all the rooms are but
most people are familiar with the room
of the painted table that's actually
what the room is called in a dragon
stone like in King's Landing you have
the red key makers holdfast the room
where the painted table is in
Dragonstone is just called the room of
the painted table you can see just like
the TV shows done with the Iron Throne
they've really like shrunk things down
because the painted table is supposed to
be about 50 feet long in the books and
this looks like it's maybe half that and
there is like a special chair that's in
the room of the painted table where
Aegon would be able to see the entire
map because normally you'd have to like
walk up and down the table to see things
really clearly but I'm guessing that
Daenerys this throne is going to be in
the Great Hall so just to go down the
list these are like the big rooms and
Dragonstone in the even cooler thing is
that they're supposedly a lot of hidden
chambers that lead down to the heart of
Dragonstone
so maybe Daenerys will explore while she
is there but it's pretty fair to say
that we're going to see most of
Dragonstone so just going down the list
there's the stone drum which is like the
central keep he got the name just
because weather would beat it when there
were really bad storms and it would
sound like someone was banging a drum so
thus the stone drum but it's in here
that there's supposedly hidden
passageways that go down to the heart of
the mountain so anybody that's hoping to
find a secret clutch of dragon eggs that
would probably be petrified by now they
would probably be down there then next
big room is the chamber of The Painted
table which I just explained it's
basically the room just for the table
for battle planning purposes so then
there's the Great Hall which looks a
little bit more like the throne room and
Kings Landing I mean obviously it's not
that big but it's a much bigger open
room where it'd be easier for Daenerys
to meet with her small Council whatever
that's going to be think of it like
winter fells Great Hall where Sansa and
John are holding Court here with the
people at the end of season six it's
kind of like a bigger much grander
version of that so I'm guessing that's
where this throne is going to be but
then there's a garden which is exactly
what it sounds like just a small vault
in place with trees growing tall on
every side with roses cranberries so
kind of a stark contrast from the other
places we've seen a dragon stone so far
which seemed devoid of life but then
there's the wind worm which is kind of
like the tallest tower you can kind of
see it here there's the sea dragon tower
which is close to the sea this is where
the maesters quarters are so maester
Cressen if you remember him from the
first couple of seasons this is where
his chambers were and then there's the
Sept which is where all the idols of the
seven gods were before Stannis burned
them in the early seasons they threw all
the idols on the fire maester Cressen
was freaking out crapping his pants even
Davos was skeptical which he was right
to be skeptical about Melisandre but
that's about all we've seen a dragon
stone so far so I would expect because
there's so much stuff happening there in
season seven that they'll just be poking
around there just like we've seen
different parts of the red keep in
King's Landing throughout the seasons
like you know really big location so
they try to film it in different ways
each season but because we haven't been
to Dragonstone in a long time and we've
only seen a couple rooms
there's just so many more places for
them to explore so expect some really
cool scenes inside dragon stone with
Daenerys just walking around trying to
get reacquainted with it because she was
born here but as a child she was
secretive across to Essos so she didn't
live here for that long so she probably
doesn't have a really great memory of it
but I just like the idea of her kind of
like taking her place in her Targaryen
ancestral home on a throne just leading
into what's going to be happening the
final a couple seasons with the battle
for the Iron Throne so even though
there's still some really big seats in
Westeros like you have the sea stone
chair over in the Iron Islands you have
the Great Hall in Winterfell but in
terms of like spectacular
bones you have Daenerys here in
Dragonstone now in Searcy obviously with
the Iron Throne but let me know what you
guys think dragon stone is probably
going to be one of the coolest sets for
next year the thing is is that it's kind
of a challenge for the production people
in that there's an extra level of ornate
detail carvings stone carvings all over
the place
so there are basilisks cockatrices
demons Griffins hellhounds manticores
minotaurs wyverns in all kinds of other
minor creatures just carved into the
rock all over the place so I'll be
interested to see how crazy they get
with that like you kind of see this
dragon carved into the wall this is in
the room of the painted table where
Stannis spends most of his time just
staring at the table itself but most of
the design is meant to be dragon centric
so you know wherever you see characters
standing in frame just expect there to
be dragging stuff in the background and
really subtle ways just kind of carved
into the walls but the funny thing is is
that dragon stone sounds like such a
cool place
Stannis always felt like Robert thrusted
upon him he's like I never asked for
dragon stone I never requested it he
always felt like it was a slight like
Robert was banishing him to Dragonstone
rather than giving him dragon stone so
just let me know
what you want them to do with those sets
next year like how do you want them to
use dragon stone itself besides the plot
obviously there's going to be a lot of
dragonglass they're probably going to
try and learn how to make Valyrian steel
again although finding a lot of
dragonglass is a lot easier
Fleance steel is like a whole level
above that that's going to require some
help from the Citadel and Samwell but
I'll say congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Jordy Lyons you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details and
there's a new round that starts now
there's a couple big things that are
happening in the next week or two so I
might post a couple more bonus videos
than I would normally post for Game of
Thrones so all you have to do to enter
the new giveaway just be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video in just a
quick heads-up - I just noticed in the
last couple of hours YouTube changed the
mobile app so if you're watching my
videos on your mobile phone
subscriptions are way down at the bottom
now so it's just closer to your thumb I
think that's why they put it down there
so they push all the garbage up here to
the top so
descriptions is where you find the
important stuff like way down here at
the bottom so new Walking Dead new
Marvel posting tomorrow what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my reaction to the supposed spoilers
for season 7 and you can click here to
learn all about Jon Snow maybe showing
up in Daenerys as visions on the TV show
the way the TV shows change things so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you